I love how open and candid you guys have
been about the UPS the downs the good
times the bad times after 10 years what
are you most proud of with your
relationship with your marriage for me
is just the growth it just gets better
in our relationship we've definitely
kind of had to not start over but
rebirth the relationship as something
that was new and kind of moving on
towards the future and by doing that
we've had this like great amazing like
rebirth of a relationship and it's just
sure you know I was just thinking about
it in the car ride over here I was just
thinking how grateful I am and how well
the gratitude I am that we're still
together is wonderful I have these
wonderful babies with you I had this
wonderful life with you and I was just
thinking about all the way over I'm just
I'm so grateful and happy definitely
need defied what society has told us you
know a relationship should be monogamy
should be this is what happens when
indiscretion happens and it can't go
forward and you know we've kind of
thrown all that out the window and just
focused on each other and what's grown
is something that has been even more
amazing than either of us thought could
ever be